earlier today I chaired meetings of the
cabinet and Cobra to consider the advice
from sage on the impact of the existing
social distancing measures there are
indications that the measures have been
put it that we put in place have been
successful in slowing down the spread of
this virus but sage also say that it is
a mixed and inconsistent picture and in
some settings infections are still
likely to be increasing sage assess that
the rate of infection or the so-called
r-value is almost certainly below one in
the community and that means that on
average each person that's infected in
turn affects less than one other person
but overall we still don't have the
infection rate down as far as we need to
as in other countries we have issues
with the virus spreading in some
hospitals and in care homes and in some
the very clear advice we received is
that any change to our social distance
social distancing measures now would
risk a significant increase in the
spread of the virus that would threaten
a second peak of the virus and
substantially increase the number of
deaths it would undo the progress that
we've made to date and as a result would
require an even longer period of the
more restrictive social distancing
measures so early relaxation would do
more damage to the economy over the
longer period over a longer period and I
want to be really clear about this the
advice from Sage is that relaxing any of
the measures currently in place would
re-establish to both public health and
our economy Patrick and Chris will be
able to go into further details on all
of this shortly but based on this advice
which we've very carefully considered
the government has decided that the
current measures must remain in place
for at least the next three weeks